you know I don't take for granted that
people just admire what we do so
whatever we do they'll admire when
people talk about boredom for example I
can honestly say I've never been bored
for a second of my life but I've always
found another way not to be if you name
any band from kind of the mid 70s we
probably opened for them you can't get
together with three people and say well
we want to have a career spanning over
20 years and I were really loyal here's
the plan
yeah here's the plan when people come up
and say something like that you
influenced me to play drums I say
apologize to your parents for me I
stopped reading reviews long ago because
if I believed the good ones I'd have to
believe the bad ones it's a good point
and most of my rhythmic growth is
evolutionary he's a Canadian American
musician and author he's best known as
the drummer and primary lyricist for the
rock band Rush he's received numerous
awards for his musical performances he's
Neil Peart and here's my take on his top
ten rules for success number two is my
personal favorite some curious to find
out which one you guys like the most you
know I don't take for granted that
people just admire what we do so
whatever we do they'll admire no you
know I feel like in fact this is very
true every audience I feel like we have
to earn them you know that we have to
earn their dedication and their
expenditure of time and energy and money
to be there every single time you know
every show and it's an old show business
thing but I really feel that you're only
as good as your last show and that's the
one thing I do like about touring if you
have a bad one
get another chance it seems like you're
you're a man of your streams like you
don't just drum you drum on one of the
largest kits there is you don't just
ride motorcycles you ride $50,000 I'm an
extremist even when you you describe
your appetite for reading - it seems
like a voracious appetite for reading
like I guess is it is that a is that I
guess is that what got you where you are
as a drummer I would expect that it all
comes down to a kind of restlessness
because I when people talk about boredom
for example I can honestly say I've
never been bored for a second of my life
but I've always found another way not to
be and like if I have to go to medical
appointments I'm like I bring a book
with me so that waiting is not going to
be a hardship but the early days of
touring when all that dead time was
hanging on me reading portable useful
you know nurturing all that stuff so I
think I come back you learn to adapt to
your own personality and and the
extremes to come in there
- yeah I wanted to read every book ever
written drumming wise my determination
was more important than talent early on
I think for most things you do have to
have a bit of a knack but I had to work
so hard to learn so many things but I
was relentless in terms of determination
and with traveling when I've got a day I
am tempted by what's the most excellent
thing I can do which might be way too
far way too long but I'm going to go for
that because it's the most excellent
thing I can do and with writing it just
seems unstinting in the same way because
I'm I have a kind of know when I've done
my best on it and maybe an editor can
help make it better and maybe somebody
else could have written it better but I
have a good built-in sense of this is
the best I could do
I'd kind of accepted the definition and
applied it myself yes I'm a
compositional drummer and then in the
same breath haven't wait a minute I want
to be an improvisational drummer you
know so um so I'd also push myself out
of my comfort zone and even my solos in
the past were always improvised over a
carefully structured framework but I
wanted even that to be freer to say okay
it's it's a performance in front of
people so it's not going to be like just
coming here and playing for a couple
hours for myself it is a performance and
I wanted to have a certain standard of
repeatability you know so that it's
going to be satisfying for me and for
the audience every night so that's a
hard line to walk to but I did work over
the course of the tour achieved that and
I think we did 44 shows on this first
part of the tour in this summer in this
fall and towards the end I was getting
so outside I remember I thought one day
bolero I'm gonna put bolero over top of
the Chicago one and did it you know and
that I what I love about my warmup - it
has the same freedom is that every I'm
about half hour before showtime
I go in and play for 20 minutes and just
play it's the same thing and I usually I
use those three with Mikkel events that
are my foundation right now but there's
no consequences it doesn't matter what
happens so I would just in my warm up
that night I tried putting a bolero over
top of it it worked it's okay and I went
in my solo that night and that certain
freshness that I loved and I've been
holding on more of the last couple tours
is being able to do that just say okay
and I've almost got this I've almost got
this I'm going to try it
who ever an opening act for so long and
we had a really good relationship with
the guy guys in kiss and their crew and
we opened for Aerosmith like 40 times
and never got a sound check and I mean
blue eyes to call it Ted Nugent if you
name any band from kind of the mid 70s
we probably opened for them because we
were an opening act and then we'd start
headlining small halls and still be
opening shows you know in between so we
had that mixed bag for a long time which
really contributed to our balance I
think you know we learned a lot about
character studies from watching other
people and some of the lyrics that I've
written on the subject and thoughts that
I've expressed on the subject of Fame
and celebrity or from witnessing how
people like that behaved and handled it
and in turn how they came out
Neil Peart is the drummer of course with
Rush thirty million albums sold it is
quite incredible over 22 years this is a
fixture on the Canadian landscape do you
have any understanding why I know it's
an often ask your talented and good but
well know that obviously we know that's
not enough even where it true but it's
an often asked question and one which no
one knows the real answer if they did
they would bottle it and sell it
while aspiring young musicians but
obviously we're glad that it's so but
you can't get together with three people
and say well we want to have a career
spanning over 20 years and I were really
loyal is the plan yeah here's the plan
so we just did what we thought was right
made music that we liked and hope that
other people would do and so far that's
been the secret formula my inspiration I
think is the what is the rewarding thing
and when people come up and say
something like that you influenced me to
play drums I say apologize to your
parents for me and music is certainly
about sharing your enthusiasm and the
nature of rushes we love our music and
we hope other people will like it too
it's there's nothing calculated more
than that about it and in the writing
too these are things that I was moved to
write about and to craft carefully
enough that I hope I can share with a
reader and if you do infect them with
your fire oh that's good enthusiasm the
literal meaning of enthusiasm is
infected with the God and if you can
share that god of yours that fire of
yours
to light someone else's that's a great
thing too we talked about the magazine
that said you were the one of the year
the best living drummer there's another
poll it would that brings your lyrics
and the question how did you feel when
you read that hello they said owner very
good lyricist but I'm sure that
obviously people disagree with it but
when you read that how do you feel you
know it can't help but be stung you know
I don't think anyone that I would want
to know would be above that you know and
it's actually the beautiful illustration
another author Tom Robbins I I was
always a great admirer of his novels and
I love the way they kept getting better
and more adventurous every time there
was one of his I think it was skinny
legs and all that there was just a
scathing review in the New York Times by
a [ __ ] so I just I got angry about it I
wrote to Tom Robbins said look as a
longtime reader I just want you to know
that your readers are more than
satisfied and I love the way you keep
progressing etc and he wrote me a really
nice answer and said I stopped reading
reviews long ago because if I believe
the good ones I'd have to believe the
bad ones and I took that sort of heart
and I'd never read another review well I
really I tend to write for a general
reader and in the case of this book
certainly I was writing for someone who
doesn't know anything about Roth rush or
rock or motorcycling or any of that I
figure it's my job to make it
interesting as the other travel writers
that I admire and in every case it was
easier with what I'm writing about by
sticking in Africa then it's obviously
not a rush boat when I'm motorcycling
around the u.s. are driving and
listening to music it was about music
but it really wasn't about me as a as a
rock drummer and this time I used all of
the same approaches of my ideal audience
someone who's curious and intelligent
about stuff but again doesn't there
necessarily know anything about my
preoccupations so I was very clearly
writing for that imaginary audience in
the same way that songwriting is for
imaginary listener or even when I'm
rehearsing for a tour it's for an
imaginary audience that I'm doing myself
up so there's that kind of it's an ideal
sense but it's also based on what I
would expect from when I went out
because I love reading travel books
myself and are those experiences it's a
good point and most of my rhythmic
growth is evolutionary so that what I've
worked on grows into something else
grows into something else but there have
been the odd time that I would call
epiphanies like that and there's a
rhythm that I used a lot in the late 80s
or so Nigerian
music West African music with a slightly
displaced accents in it and I heard that
I was in a village in Togo in West
Africa on your ten-speed on a traveling
by bicycle that time and just I heard
this rhythm I'm echoing across the
valley and it was just two drummers with
hand drums playing it and it engraved
itself on my mind and became a huge
influence on me rhythmically after that
because I had been listening to King
Sonny a day was a pioneer for Nigerian
pop music and a certain certain real mix
rhythmic accent syncopations that would
based on that I was very influenced by
at the time and then this other rhythm
that I heard that time in Togo was from
that same heart and the music that I
heard no it lodges itself am i bringing
it it ain't great itself in there and
and that becomes something special and
those are rare I think when you're
suddenly a hit by something that's that
strong reggae the first time reggae
music really got into my soul and I felt
that upbeat downbeat mention I God again
I'll never forget it was a Bob Marley
song natural mystic yeah
just sitting in a car and hearing that
song and I suddenly I got it you know I
got what reggae was all about where I'd
heard it before but hadn't got it you
write in your book because you're
talking to the Arctic writing you say
imagine riding and planting roots and
everything is it magic exists but often
requires something but you're talking
about writing I think it also it seems
also apply to the music evenly you have
some planning but then there's that room
problem well said absolutely so yeah all
that effort of study and I was that the
early records that the three of us made
together we were experimenting we were
learning how to play our instruments
we were learning how to write songs we
were learning how to arrange especially
through say farewell to King's
hemispheres we were learning so much
about arrangement and orchestration in
the sense of a three-piece rock band and
all of that gathered together and then
by say my moving picture 1980 so we've
been together six years by that time and
then we gelled and all of those studies
all those courses of study that we went
through together
with pure innocence and pure enthusiasm
suddenly they became a unified approach
that moving pictures and from then on
carried for us and then as that time
even from that time yeah we continue to
experiment absolutely with different
kinds of songs different kind of
Arrangements orchestrations of all kinds
different producers there's another good
example you can get comfortable working
with the same producer and then some
people do their whole career but we
always felt we wanted a new brains to
pick and new criticisms new enthusiasms
just new new opinions even thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Sam Mac asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of the top ten
rules hit you the hardest the biggest
impact on you and why which one was your
favorite leave it in the comments and I
will join the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon